A beloved mentally unstable, masked vigilante
once said, “I’m not trapped in here with
you, you’re trapped in here with me!”
And this exact sentiment was shared by SPCP-682,
the Hard to Destroy Reptile, as it traversed
the almost limitless, liminal hell known as
The Backrooms.
It’d been little more than a standard “chase
and secure” mission for the Mobile Task
Forces pursuing SCP-682 after its latest deadly
containment breach, until the vicious lizard
made its way into an abandoned warehouse and
no clipped its way into a new reality.
As the SCP Foundation are still desperately
searching for the missing beast back in our
native reality, 682 has been discovering whole
new vistas of violence.
First, it found itself in the endless yellow
halls of Level Zero, where if the madness
doesn’t get you, the starvation and thirst
will - Well, unless you’re an anomalous
reptilian abomination that can seemingly adapt
to any situation.
Once 682 escaped this gaudy purgatory, it
found its way into Level One, an endless warehouse
full of equal parts monsters and hapless human
settlers - all of whom it decimated in a single
bloody afternoon.
Then, onto Level Two, the Pipe Rooms, where
it faced a bevy of beasts that it eagerly
put into the ground.
And that brings us up to now - And, by extension,
onto Level Three.
SCP-682 spilled out into another section of
long, industrial hallways.
It didn’t know how it had gotten in, and
honestly, it didn’t really care at this
point.
All it needed to do was keep moving forward
and killing as it pleased, and it seemed there
were plenty of creatures down here to kill.
That being said, this level had a certain
energy to it.
And we mean that literally: 682’s incredibly
sensitive…
Well, senses, allowed it to detect an incredibly
powerful electrical field emanating from this
level.
And from the sounds of machines humming all
around it, traveling down great bundles of
wires and pipes bound to the walls, it knew
that this level must have been attached to
a generator of truly incredible size.
It charged forward, weaving around the different
hallways at freakish speeds, searching for
the next thing it could blast into oblivion.
And thankfully, it was able to find its first
target soon enough.
A nest of creatures known as Death Moths.
These were huge, fluttering moths of freakish
size, congregating around a glowing electrical
outlet.
Intriguing.
SCP-682 decided to approach and introduce
itself - After all, they looked like pretty
easy prey.
682 would regret this oversight.
While the male Death Moths are pretty much
harmless, the female Death Moths have an extremely
potent defense mechanism.
As SCP-682 approached, the creatures began
swarming and spraying acid onto its reptilian
flesh.
This was painful and irritating for 682, of
course, but if any entity on earth is pretty
accustomed to dealing with large quantities
of powerful acid by now, it’s SCP-682.
Its skin quickly healed from the acidic onslaught
and it developed a powerful counteradaptation:
A long, sticky, frog-like tongue, which it
used to devour the nest full of Death Moths
and move along to its next target.
It continued exploring Level 3.
A number of hallways were marked off with
metal bars - another very familiar sight for
SCP-682 - so, for simplicity’s sake, it
just kept itself to the unobstructed paths.
That’s where it soon ran into another lifeform,
standing around like a sitting duck in one
of the level’s many anonymous hallways.
It was just another human, in a similar outfit
to all those “Major Explorer Group” weaklings
it had destroyed earlier.
Strangely, even when SCP-682 entered the hallway
with it, it didn’t seem to react properly.
It just vacantly stared off into space, stumbling
around awkwardly.
682, bemused, whipped this random, disoriented
stranger in the chest with its tail, sending
him sailing into the nearby wall.
It was at this point that something strange
happened: The force of the strike caused the
man’s clothes, and also skin, to disintegrate,
leaving something entirely different underneath.
SCP-682 had no idea what was going on, but
it knew that it hated it.
This was its first encounter with a creature
known as a Skin Stealer.
It would be natural for a human being to be
terrified of an abomination like this.
An apex predator like 682, on the other hand?
It barely even found the Skin Stealer interesting.
With a single stomp from its clawed, reptilian
foot, the creature was very, very dead, and
SCP-682 continued its journey through the
bowels of Level 3.
It found itself drawn to whatever the source
of all the energy was, if it even had one
single source.
It was almost as though the entire level was
one giant generator, powering the rest of
the Backrooms.
And if there was electricity, perhaps there
were other humans in here to kill…
SCP-682 liked that idea very much indeed.
However, while making its way down a slightly
wider hallway - one that it had previously
believed was completely uninhabited - it was
suddenly ambushed by a group of mysterious
attackers.
A number of tall, grey creatures with long,
clawing arms and unclear facial features stepped
away from the wall.
These entities are known as the Dullers, ambush
predators native to the Backrooms.
They normally run away from threats, but considering
the number of them congregated in the hall
around SCP-682, perhaps they felt a little
more confident about taking down their prey
in a group.
But they’d made a grave calculation: It
wouldn’t matter whether there was one Duller
or a thousand Dullers.
In the battle between them and SCP-682, they
would always, always, always be the prey.
But lucky for them, while they weren’t aware
of this immutable fact yet, SCP-682 was more
than happy to give them a first-hand education.
While the Dullers tried their best to claw
into 682’s thick, leathery hide, the creature
decided to employ a new ability it had stolen
from the female Death Moths.
Several new glands developed all over 682’s
body, each of which produced a fine mist of
highly concentrated acid.
Soon enough, the Dullers were howling in pain,
and melting away into dull, grey puddles on
the ground, never to reconstitute again.
That’s what you get for trying to climb
up the food chain, folks.
It never ends well.
Unless you’re 682, that is.
After disposing of the Dullers - which, in
682’s own humble opinion had more than earned
that title by indeed being extremely dull
- it decided to continue its search for some
of the power sources on this level.
Perhaps it could harness this ability for
its own benefit.
But it was interrupted by what is, frankly,
one of the grossesst enemies in all of the
Backrooms: The Bursters.
And if even hearing that name made you feel
a little sick, then you’re correctly primed
for what you’re about to encounter.
They’re humanoid creatures that walk around
on all fours, with its back legs grotesquely
stretched out into the shape of a dog’s
hind legs.
But that’s nothing compared to a Burster’s
truly diabolical backne.
All over the creature’s back, you can see
huge, callused cysts that contain a potent
and noxious acid.
Sure, the acid is only about as dangerous
as the stuff produced by female Death Moths,
but in our humble opinion, the method of acid
delivery is far more repulsive, and that makes
Bursters less desirable to encounter.
A small group of them skittered out of the
darkness towards SCP-682.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile also found them
disgusting - though now that we think about
it, SCP-682 thinks all forms of life are disgusting,
so we suppose it’s all relative.
However, when they began to burst their backs
and coat 682 in their horrible pus, they perhaps
earned the rarely-given label of “extra
disgusting” from this living embodiment
of reptilian hate.
682 quickly retaliated by clawing the horrid
creatures to death, which I think we can all
agree is a good and well-deserved ending for
the vile little beasts.
We would have done the same thing.
The next enemies that 682 encountered weren’t
nightmarish creatures, but in fact, were human
beings stationed in the Major Explorer Group’s
Base Gamma, the third most important base
in all of the Backrooms.
They were on high alert after losing contact
with Base Alpha several days before - Having
no idea that everyone at that base had been
slaughtered by SCP-682, a fate that, if they
weren’t tremendously lucky, they would soon
share.
But they had a little more than luck on their
side this time…
SCP-682 sighted the base on the end of a long
hallway.
There was even a person standing at the other
end of the hall, seemingly blissfully unaware
of the encroaching presence of one of the
SCP Foundation’s most dangerous and formidable
captives. 682 loved killing humans most of
all - They weren’t just dumb animals, they
had the intellectual capacity to actually
appreciate the life that was being ripped
away from them, and it made the whole act
even more pleasurable for SCP-682.
It set its sights on the ignorant Major Explorer
Group member leaning against the distant wall,
and decided to charge for him, claws extended
and fangs bared.
This would be such easy prey.
Until the moment when someone in the distance
yelled, “NOW!”, and the seemingly defenseless
human turned around and pulled a level on
the wall.
Suddenly, the whole hallway was electrified,
sending millions of volts coursing through
SCP-682’s writhing body.
This whole thing had been an elaborate trap!
The humans at Base Gamma hadn’t survived
this long in the Backrooms by being stupid.
The more technically savvy members had rewired
some of the hallways to channel the immense
energy of the generators, and fry any unfortunate
entities that tried to use these hallways
to break into Base Gamma.
There was one big problem, though: SCP-682
wasn’t just any unfortunate entity.
While it initially looked like the electrcity
might fry the beast, it gradually began channeling
the electricity into its own body, and developing
the capacity to regift this electricity to
the people who so kindly provided it.
SCP-682, now a crackling conduit of electrcity,
leaped from the shocking hallway and into
Base Gamma.
Soon enough, it had fatally electrocuted all
300 members of the Major Explorer Group posted
in Base Gamma, and returned to its baseline
state.
Level 3 had grown tiresome now - It seemed
there were no more exciting new creatures
to massacre.
As a result, 682 slid into a nearby elevator,
and went down, where a new level awaited.
This was how SCP-682 got to Level 4.
And Level 4 was not what the Hard to Destroy
Reptile expected.
In contrast to the industrial nightmare of
the previous few levels, Level 4 was like
a limitless office block with all the furniture
ripped out.
While for some this might represent the crushing,
existential banality of office life, and how
the wheels of capitalism inevitably work us
to death, SCP-682 had never worked in an office
before, so it didn’t really have the proper
cultural reference points to appreciate this
more abstract kind of fear.
It wanted monsters to kill!
682 spent approximately six days searching
around the hellscape that is Level 4, not
discovering a single person or entity while
it was there.
It was honestly the most stressed that SCP-682
had felt since coming here.
The beast was almost tempted to unscrew a
lightbulb from above, draw a little face on
it, begin referring to it as “Wilson”,
and then kill it.
682 felt the closest emotion it could manage
to immense gratitude when it sighted the glowing
green of a distant exit sign at the end of
a long hallway.
Finally, a way out onto another level!
Hopefully this one would have more creatures
to slaughter…
Welcome, SCP-682, to Level 5.
SCP-682 didn’t really know what to expect
from the next level of the Backrooms - After
all, it’d all seemed pretty random so far
- but it definitely didn’t expect to see
a classy, well-appointed hotel on the other
end of that hallway.
SCP-682 had never seen the Stanley Kubrik
Masterpiece, The Shining, nor read the book
it was based on by Master of Horror Stephen
King, but if it had, it would probably have
drawn the comparison.
Instead, it was already busy tearing through
the ornate halls, looking for new prey to
slaughter.
The first unexpected encounter was with a
small cat that casually wandered out into
the hallway, right in front of it.
The cat, who didn’t seem threatened by SCP-682,
said, “Hi, I’m Samantha.
You got any meat you can lend me?
I’ll tell your fortune if you do.”
SCP-682 was, frankly, baffled.
It took a moment to formulate a reply.
“You worthless creature.
You have no idea what you’re dealing with,
do you?
I’m going to bring this place to ruin, and
destroy all who reside within,” 682 said.
“So no meat, then?”
682 growled and swiped at the cat with its
claws.
Luckily, she was able to dodge.
The cat tutted and padded away into the darkness,
muttering, “Go bother the Beast instead.
Jerk.”
This piqued SCP-682’s interest.
A Beast, you say?
Sounds important, sounds powerful.
Finally, a worthy opponent!
Our battle shall be legendary!
And with renewed vigor, SCP-682 began prowling
the halls of the Backrooms, searching for
this “Beast” to defeat and destroy.
But to begin with, things were grievously
disappointing.
One of the first monsters on this opulent
hotel level that the Hard to Destroy Reptile
faced were diminutive little rodents known
as Death Rats, which were effectively slightly
larger than normal rats with little horns.
SCP-682 stomped them all with ease, its thoughts
dripping with disdain for their truly pathetic
weakness.
What kind of a hotel allows itself to be filled
with rats?
Even by human standards, this would be disgraceful.
Soon after, SCP-682 encountered a few familiar
foes: Female Death Moths and Hounds, all as
easy to kill as they were before.
SCP-682 didn’t understand: The feline promised
that there was a Beast down here.
Was it hiding from the mighty reptile like
a filthy coward?
Worthless!
But it was in the depths of this cynicism
that SCP-682 encountered a Growler.
First, it heard the sound of animalistic growling
projected directly into its mind, getting
louder and louder by the moment.
Then, as the growling grew in volume, 682
heard the thundrous footsteps of a huge quadruped
getting closer.
682 wondered, as the roaring became almost
deafening, whether this sound heralded the
approach of the Beast.
However, the second the monster actually turned
the corner and came into view, 682 had to
suppress the urge to laugh.
It was one of the more absurd things it’d
ever seen.
It looked like a giant pile of pipe cleaners,
in every color imaginable, arranged into a
vaguely four-legged structure.
This was the monster producing all that psychic
racket?
Pathetic!
SCP-682 resolved, in that moment, to show
the monster how it was done.
SCP-682 immediately evolved its own psychic
emission capacitors within its brain, and
projected the message “YOU ARE A WORTHLESS
LITTLE CREATURE” directly into the simple
mind of the Growler.
It began to quake in horror at the booming
of 682’s voice in its brain.
What was this terrifying new creature?
It didn’t understand.
And just like that, 682, who had grown bored
of this one-sided psychic battle, turned up
the strength of the psychic beam by a factor
of fifty.
The sudden psychic blast was so powerful that
the Growler collapsed to the ground and burst
into flames, burning itself away into nothingness
in a matter of moments.
Just as weak as 682 had expected.
Hopefully, the Beast would provide a greater
challenge, because this was just getting sad.
SCP-682 shook off the disappointment and continued
running through the halls of the hotel.
Eventually, after passing through some dull
dance hall called “the Beverly Room”,
682 found itself running through a hallway
full of long portraits.
Every person in the portraits had a strange,
twisted grin on their face - Not that this
even registered to SCP-682.
What did occur to 682, though, was the figure
that suddenly materialized in the hallway
in front of it.
It was a strange figure, to be sure, an entity
in a suit, with a large, blue cuttlefish for
a head.
The creature cleared its throat and began
to speak.
“Well hello there.
You’re new here, aren’t you?
Such an interesting creature.
You’ve been making some trouble on the other
levels, haven’t you?
Not that it’s any of my business.
On the contrary, dear sir, I like the cut
of your jib.
How would you feel about joining me in the
hotel business?
It isn’t easy to manage this dimension by
myself, after all.
How about you and I come to my office, we
can work out the terms of our--”
682 lunged forward and unceremoniously devoured
the creature’s head, allowing its dapperly-dressed
body to fall limply to the ground, dead.
SCP-682 grunted, annoyed by the distraction
the creature had provided.
682 had better things to do.
This Beast has got to be around here somewhere…
Want to learn more about The Backrooms?
Check out our new sister channel, The Backrooms
Explained, where we’re exploring the Backrooms
level by level and uncovering all of its secrets!
Now go check out “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” and
“SCP-682 vs SCP Foundation - Hard To Destroy
Reptile Termination Attempts” for more of
everyone’s favorite ornery reptile!